ソフトクリームが食べたい
こんにちは
ドクターー...
ソフトクリームが食べたい
私ソフトクリームが食べたい
もちろんアイスではない
ソフトクリームが食べたいのだ
なぜならあの螺旋状(らせんじょう)にツイストする
ソフトクリームの流れ
あれこそ人類がゲノム
DNAなのだよ
ソフトクリーム食べたいんですよ
私ソフトクリームが食べたいのだが
自宅で食べたい
わがままなんだ
自宅でソフトクリームを食べたいが
ソフトクリームは基本お店とかにしか売ってないので
私は作れない訳である
つなり
つまり
この家だとソフトクリームが作ることができないので
どこかで買ったソフトクリームを瞬時にこの家に持ってくるしかない
ただその過程においてソフトクリームが熱によって溶ける可能性がかなり高い
というかほぼ確実に溶けてしまう
つまり
食べられない
家に着く前に無くなってしまう
だが、案ずるでない
率直に言えば購入して家に運ぶまで過程で溶けるのは仕方ない時間として
その時間は最小限に抑えた上で
自宅に運んだ溶けかけのソフトクリームを瞬時に食べることが可能であれば
ソフトクリームを食べることは可能であるかもしれない
すなわち
これだー！！
ソフトクリームとは別名ソフトツイスト
なぜツイストかと言うと
ねじれているからであります
ソフトクリームとは本来一本の棒状のソフトを
お店のきれいなお姉さんによって
こう、ねじることによってツイストをしていってできたのが
ソフトクリーム別名ソフトツイスト
つまり
ソフトツイストをここに置いて
逆回転でこう回転させると
こう、こう
螺旋状に磨かれていたソフトクリームが
逆回転によってこうほどけていき
僕の口に入る瞬間だけ一本の線になって
こう、何よりも早く
入るのではないか
という私は
気がするんですよ
俺、何言ってんだろう
要するに言いたいのは
こうねじれている物を逆に回すと
一本のきれいな線になるよねっていう話です
それをこの上上で瞬間的にバーンとして
バーンって食えば
溶けかけのソフトクリームも一瞬で食えるんじゃねぇか
という私の仮説である
では、ソフトクリーム、買いに行ってこよう
ハッ！
ジャーキー
早く、早く
溶けちゃう、溶けちゃう、早く
こういう時も車映っちゃうから
道路側から撮ったほうがいいよ
やばっ、溶けてる
やっぱソフトクリームホント早いっす溶けるの　「青」　あっ
はぁ、はぁ
はぁ、置く場所が
置く、置く場所、置く場所がない
ok
ヤバイ、溶けるー、速度がヤバイ
はい
はい、とゆうことで無事ソフトクリームを
持ち込むことができました
ただ、もう溶ける速度が速すぎるんで
早く付けて食べなければ
ok、ok、ok
ここさえしっかりしていれば
ここさえしっかりくっ付いていれば
はい、というわけで出来ました
では早速、食べていこうと思います
いきます
3、2、1
字幕テキトーでごめんなさいm(__)m
え、待って、こんなところまで飛んでくる？
んんっ
はいっ！